Megan a big victory for you you're
playing a uh streaking player ashrita
was coming out of three consecutive
victories how did you approach this game
I think I think she definitely had a lot
of fighting Spirit during this game and
I think she wanted to win
um so she repeated the sebastianakov but
I found like a different line than Tata
Floyd So I think I was able to maintain
like a positional Advantage you prepared
this move Knight to D5 but it seemed
like she was ready for it because she
was blitzing out her moves as well were
you worried at any point especially
before taking this Pawn on D6
yeah I think when I played Bishop D2 I
don't think that's very common so I
wasn't sure if she was still in her prep
but I think it's pretty hard to
um have it anticipated I think what I
played so
but she did play the best moves all the
way up to this move B5
were you shocked about this development
B5 uh I was a little worried but I think
if I do it takes b
um
then she can sort of have a lot of
counter play and I didn't really like
that so definitely takes B6 yeah Queen
takes B6 and E3 is coming as well did
you consider taking the B5 Pawn at any
point
um I think I wanted to keep the position
sort of closed and not let her Knight
into the game absolutely and you play
this move B3 E3 F3
I want to ask you something did you spot
any uh moves at this point outside of
what she played with Quentin D6 uh I
thought she was maybe gonna do like
Queen E7 or like a knight H5 Knight F4
and try to
um did you spot this move
[Music]
um
that's a nice one yeah yeah and now if
you take with the Queen the idea is that
Queen to F6 comes with the temple
invades via B2 to F2 and this might
actually be quite worrisome for you
um she did not spot that she played very
quickly Queen to D6 and by the way
I think she played this movie in three
minutes four minutes that was quite
quick were you surprised by the way she
was playing her Pace um I think she
wanted to put a lot of pressure on the
clock so sometimes I get in time trouble
but I just try to keep steady Pace
during this game so and that you did
Bishop to E2 going to B4
and how are you feeling at this point
after replay this move G3 you get King
to G2 coming in it feels like you
stabilized the position yeah I think
once I get G3 in um it's pretty
comfortable
um there's not too many threats I have
to worry about
um so I thought she might try to do like
a night sack really yeah so you
anticipated this move Knight to E4 yeah
but I I wasn't I thought it would be
okay like I could tuck my king on H1 and
um I don't think there's that many
mating chances yep and that's exactly
what you did and that's exactly what you
were supposed to do and after that you
converted nicely well at least until
until irina's game is over you are in
Seoul leadership position how do you
feel right now after eight months I
would never imagine being in this
position I think I'm just trying to play
good chess and
um just hanging in there and how's the
job going on are you doing your work
during the day or like at night yeah I'm
doing something
my parents are really helping me out
they're at the shop right now that's
helping me so I really appreciate them
very nice very nice guys
our congratulations Megan and I thought
that the way you defended uh the peace
sacrifice is really nice I mean just
kept everything as you said tucked your
king away and it all went splendidly Yes
actually
about Megan and Wikipedia it's written
she runs two businesses she's a business
woman
how is it going I mean let's say how
does it fit with chess's career I mean
it was just interesting to know more
about it like how modern lady manages
all these things all together it's not
it's not enough to be a grand master you
have to have two businesses how do you
manage your businesses I
it's pretty hard
I don't have that much free time
um but I try to do like everything and
is it definitely business
um no I actually bought it myself but my
parents like really helped me out so
that I could be yeah there is an online
shop actually with many many nice
products and I was thinking to buy some
yeah
what's your website
um shopsnipot.com sorry one more time
please uh shop snippet.com
snippet yes yes snip it snippet yes
snippet yes and there are some nice nice
things you can buy not I didn't find
anything related with chess maybe it's
time to do something it's really popular
what's your most popular seller
um I think people really like pins and
yes there are some nice pieces
okay I have to look yeah you have to
look now it's time to speak about it
thank you so much I mean it's really
encourage encouraging for also young
girl chess players you know you should
try to find different ways yes
absolutely just looking with Jennifer
who